today our answer in the question is it
better fried and also what was that that
I just ate we're gonna try some deep
fried food see what the [ __ ] they are
even when I wasn't vegan I don't think I
was particularly drawn to fried food I
am really nervous fried food came from
that they had been boiling food and they
just thought well let's boil it in this
and then it was like oh [ __ ] batter up
it's completely indistinguishable got a
good crisp on the outside it's no sweet
like raspberries just gonna guess donut
they're like Nutella it's a bride key so
with no matter what it is it's a donut
I'm Emma down that's good this is not a
healthy way to eat a very healthy thing
no bananas complete mush which normally
would not be good right you yuck but
it's actually great it's like a jelly
donut but the banana is the jelly and
the fried dough is the nut there's so
much oil in my mouth why is this
exciting
I don't know if I want that I hate it it
looks like a pineapple sort of okay
[Music]
what is that do you like it
not really is this an animal orange
nickel and pumpkin fried lost the taste
of pumpkin not better fried oh it's very
crunchy this is like a heart
[Music]
it's kind of like a little mouse like
picking out the wood of like a house or
something well I can see that it's
avocado why would you do that
what is the coating Oh No
avocado is already good on its own like
you know people are always like trying
to like do the most with food I would
not serve this to anyone okay well so
much for the fun part of this video ah
another donut just tastes like rubber
bands I don't like hard-boiled eggs
because of how they taste
I cannot taste the egg in this so yes
this was improved are you guys are you
[ __ ] with me
Oh Oh it's kale no one likes you kale
even when you're fried you're an excuse
of a vegetable bad Plus fried does not
equal good it just equals fried bad oh
you know I thought it was a [ __ ]
candy bar this is a [ __ ] Twix
oh no no no Snickers it's a snap oh it
tastes like a candy bar I don't eat
protein bars so I don't think I would
eat them fried or regular both of these
things are things that come in shells
you took away their shell and gave them
new shells to see if it would make them
better and in one case it worked and one
case didn't Wow poetry